and I've been doing that all my life do
you play Monopoly with him I don't you
don't
how about chess we try to play are you
good
no I'm bad yeah yeah but you know how to
play I know what move at a time
yeah yeah that's right I'm not pretty
I'm not prison break yeah yeah what's
that kids name Magnus
yeah the magnet magnet yeah genius yeah
I can think maybe two moves ahead at
tops no you don't why cuz I know you
don't you think one move and that move
is does the horse go to the left two
moves you think of is straight and then
laughs and I know this is what did you
know this is how far my mind went is the
truth okay I'm not lying here okay
you move your rock Yeah right yeah go in
my mind that's the first time yep right
he's gonna try to trick my [ __ ] he's
trying to capture something yeah so why
did he move that rook he's trying to get
a beaver saying whatever it might be I
think right yeah and then I this is as
far as I can think if he takes this I I
have to do this if it takes this I have
to do this and then my mind will stop
mmm yeah right that's two moves up you
had me [ __ ] [ __ ] doesn't know who
Helen Hunt is how do you not know who
Helen Hunt is you know Helen huh of
course yeah yeah she said she was a deaf
girl that spoke at sign language is I'm
joking twister Bieber I go did you see
castaway I don't know that you don't
know that he's 24
I don't give a [ __ ] let me see this okay
there's kids out there that don't know
who Mark Wahlberg was at I'm being very
honest that's actually I had to explain
secretin Roy I know but not everybody
knows man we're 50 bro I know but the
thing is he was in so and i nuts
I know what
oh you're in your dad's nuts 24 years
ago splattered where do you get that
nose your mom or your dad that's it
where'd you get that voice from your mom
[Laughter]
don't get angry don't get mad these are
jokes here's my point at 19 in nineteen
when I was in high school people go do
you know who Robert Redford is that's
not my generation yeah I know where the
[ __ ] he is he was still relevant when
you were in high school do I get to
share on the phone oh god now he gets
him to the floor I don't forget forget
to share me that was stupid what they
said I'll have a dissing Orson Welles
was not in my generation okay that I can
agree but he wasn't in anyone because
his name was like like a famous name but
you didn't know who he was no I did he
was no you didn't you didn't know any of
his [ __ ] he was just a famous and
everyone always said boy I bet this
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah seemed alright
film school what do you see you see you
saw Citizen Kane okay see ya you know
well then you know who I'm gonna give
you a pass on that Helen Hunt was in
Citizen Kane yeah yeah I'm gonna give
you a pat on sorry I apologize he's in a
closet
nice man why do you mean to the kid
that's in it in the closet sitting on a
medicine ball [ __ ] humiliating for
god sakes
yeah give them the water next to a lamp
you know held by a squirrel [ __ ] are you
all those clothes you don't even wear
all of those are my girlfriend's
[Music]